hey what's up I'm Chandler Kinney and I
play willow hi I'm Pierce josa and I
play Wyatt my name is Milo Manheim and I
play Zed I'm Matt Donnally and I play
Addison I Mario Martin and I play winter
and we're the cast of zombies too and
we're playing Who's Who on BuzzFeed
[Music]
I'm not just a myself no I said she's so
nice like just today I will switch my
answer to make I said Chandler because
she is like our leader and mom of our
group yeah and so is willow she's too we
you actually have like I'm sorry who's
the only song I'm still confident in
that when I was so choose like you have
a plan but you also are like very like
outdoorsy and you there are like support
rays or emotions I'm just not it
everybody was able to connect with their
character
okay I'm gonna go with Meg I'm gonna go
with me anybody that's doing a scene
with your nose just like look at your
sex are you guys okay that's what this
is West right that's West right miss
Chandler take a selfie ever in my Sophie
it's with these two whatever there's
good like he said good lighting
I could feel the lady like when the
lighting hits and like oh listen she
feels the lighting but our selfie queen
is Carla I just like us haven't talked
about it that much
- I am one time like on the way home
like Chandler REO and I talked about the
Hannah Montana is over he has to choose
but I yeah yeah I know I just say oh my
god like High School Musical like I
lived it for me like nothing will ever
be but yeah the beach
[Music]
[Music]
I have to have deliberation time on this
one in school I feel like some yeah I
know you I forgot we're both good in
class to be here that's true we attend
we win this one
hold on hold on excuse me out of
jealousy you always do this to us yeah
it's for whatever it is if it's the the
circle or the this game like this I I
I'm pretty good at that one that came
from Mike came from one of the dancers
on the he got me a million times and I
just had to pop off here Ian period
[Music]
I know that meg is a very expressive
listen if you were to go through its so
yes so much fun